Maxwell not only unified electricity and
magnetism he also showed that light is
electromagnetism but what is light
exactly
well thankfully few of us have ever been
hit by lightning we've at least seen it
splashed across the sky
combined with our experiences with
static cling magnets and Light which are
representative phenomena of
electromagnetism we all have at least
get a basic feel for the knowledge
embodied in Maxwell's equations
although we all have personal experience
with electromagnetism our experiences
are actually pretty Limited
that's because our senses have a fairly
limited scope we're concerned with
objects from Mo the size of a grain of
sand to the journey to the next meal or
Watering Hole say a millimeter to tens
or hundreds of kilometers
we have a personal familiarity with
temperatures ranging from a polar vortex
to a roaring campfire say temperatures
from as low as minus 30 Celsius to maybe
a thousand degrees Celsius
however there are places in the universe
that are much different with conditions
that are unimaginable to us
there's the tiny Realm of the atom and
the grand sweep of the Milky Way with
temperatures ranging from so cold that
air turns into a liquid to so hot that
they can tear apart a star
it was with the opening days of the 20th
century that scientists began to take
their first tentative steps into a vast
and new world to learn about how matter
behaved under conditions that had never
been before investigated
it is therefore not at all shocking that
surprises arose in fact that's an
important lesson to keep in your mind
the lesson being that as soon as you
step outside of your comfort zone you
should expect to be surprised
as we move ahead in our journey of
trying to imagine a theory of everything
that should be your Mantra expect the
unexpected
I'll let the story tell itself but the
core idea of this lesson is an
understanding of light that unifies the
idea of a particle and the idea of a
wave
one of the oldest arguments in physics
is on the nature of light is light a
particle or a wave you'd think that'd be
easy to determine after all waves and
particles are pretty different things
waves have wavelengths frequencies and
amplitudes and extend over a large
volume
in contrast particles have a
well-defined location without the
trappings of a wave they're very
different beasts and it seems that
figuring out which of the two that light
is would be an easy task
Maxwell confirm that light is a wave but
we'll see that a fully correct answer is
a lot harder than it seems
suppose a person proposed one or the
other
at a minimum their proposal needed to
explain some of the things we see light
do for example we know that light can
reflect
that's easy to demonstrate using a
simple mirror we also know that light
refracts which is the effect whereby
light bends when it passes from Air to a
transparent solid
while early discussions began in Greek
Antiquity the arguments were essentially
philosophical until around the time of
Newton
Newton was a proponent of the particle
View
if light is a particle it's easy to
explain how light reflects it's no
different than bouncing a tennis ball
off the ground
if you assume that light travels faster
through a solid than it does through air
the particle idea can explain the
observed bending of light as well
we now know that this assumption is
exactly backwards light travels more
slowly through solid matter than it does
there but that wasn't known at the time
it was Newton's extraordinary scientific
reputation that led to the particle
theory of light to be favored for a very
long time
however the wave idea had its adherence
English scientist Robert Hook and Dutch
mathematician Christian huygen
both rough contemporaries of Newton
worked out a wave theory of light
this Theory can also explain reflection
and refraction although the refraction
explanation required that light move
more slowly in solid matter rather than
gaseous matter
we now know that this is correct however
for about 150 years there was no
measurement to prove it
a special note Huygens postulated that
there was a substance called The
luminiferous Ether which allowed light
to travel as a wave
while we no longer Believe In The Ether
theorists continue to talk about it into
the late 19th century
for lack of any evidence for ether was
an objection to the wave theory
the argument persisted until about 1800
when a series of experiments by English
polymath Thomas Young demonstrated
rather persuasively that light was
actually a wave given the definitive
nature of the experiment it's worth
spending a few minutes describing it
one of the properties of waves that is
very different from particles is that
they can interfere with one another
you can see this at the seashore when
two waves cross one another and the
result is temporarily a single but
larger wave this is called constructive
interference
similarly you can see when the peak of
one water wave encounters the trough of
another the result is that the two waves
cancel each other out and this is called
destructive interference
Young's experiment used in opaque
barrier with two adjacent slits when
light illuminated a single slit it
passes through the slit and it spreads
out
that's true of the other slit as well
now if light is a wave you'd expect it
to look like ripples in a pond that you
see when you drop a stone in the water
on the other hand both slits generate
these ripples which means that there
would be two sources of waves and as I
said before waves can interfere with one
another
there would be spots that are peaks of
one set of waves and troughs of another
set of waves which we cancel out
canceling out light means there would be
dark spots on a distant screen
similarly there would be places where
the peaks of both sets of waves would
appear at the same time and same
location resulting in bright spots on
the distance screen
and that's exactly what we see bright
spots and dark spots Young's double slit
experiment is the definitive and
inarguable demonstration that light is a
wave
after this experiment the discussion was
over Maxwell's equations of the 1860s
and 1870s simply solidified the
situation
so that was the status quo for quite a
while however in 1887 German physicist
Heinrich Hertz did an experiment that
was most puzzling indeed
what he was doing was taking two
electrodes and attaching them to both
ends of a very strong battery
if he did so occasionally a spark would
jump between the electrodes you might
have seen a similar sort of thing if
you've ever tried to jump start a car
so Sparks were nothing new but hertz's
real contribution was that he saw that
if he illuminated the electrodes with an
ultraviolet light the Sparks occurred
more easily than if the same experiment
was done in the dark
so that was kind of cool the initial
explanation was that the electromagnetic
field was knocking out some of the
electrons from the electrodes which then
started a chain reaction actually even
now that's what we think but there's
more
people started playing around with the
parameters that Define the light those
are actually only two important things
the first is the color of the light in
wave terms this was the wavelength while
the second important thing is the
brightness for a wave that's the
amplitude
so what did they see
well the first thing people saw was that
the color of the light seemed to matter
if you used red light you've got no
spark enhancement this was also true for
orange and yellow light it was also true
for green blue and purple but when the
light was ultraviolet the Sparks would
form
by the way just to be honest I'm talking
about electrodes made of a certain
element there are a few elements such as
the high mass Alkali out metals like
cesium for example they would spark when
irradiated by visible light but the
basic pattern is unchanged for all
materials certain colors visible or not
will induce a spark While others won't
so there are a couple of things to keep
in mind first is that whole Roy G Biv
thing which are the colors of the
rainbow in order they are red orange
yellow green blue indigo and violet
further the color of light is determined
by the wavelength with the red being
long wavelength and the Violet being
shorter or if you prefer you can use the
fact that the wavelength and frequency
of light is related by the mathematical
relationship frequency times wavelength
equals the speed of light that means red
light is low frequency while purple
light is high frequency
so this says that high frequency or
equivalently short wavelength light can
cause a spark while low frequency and
long wavelength light can't
so that's the first observation
second observation is that if you shine
low frequency light on the electrode you
can crank the brightness Higher and
Higher and you get no spark
you could turn it up to the point where
the brightness is overwhelming and it
still just wouldn't budge a sparkle
meter
so that's where things get tricky
remember that Young's double slit
experiment established that light was a
wave and waves have certain properties
one of them is that the energy of the
wave is dependent on the amplitude thus
if you cranked up the brightness you
should be hitting the electrode with
more energy well if light were a wave
anyway so so much for the wave idea
[Music]
thank you